OK, just to put this out there, perhaps you are somebody who has not been looking forward to the inevitable deluge of 10th anniversary 9/11 coverage on basically every media outlet that exists. But think for a second about what it's like for the 9/11 families and survivors. Like Lynn Simpson. She was on the first show we did after 9/11, telling the story of working on the 89th floor of World Trade Center One when the planes hit, and how she made it down the stairs and out of the building with about a minute to spare. I caught up with her last week.
好吧，先说明一下，也许你并不期待媒体对9/11十周年的狂轰滥炸式报道。但请花点时间想一想，这对9/11受害者家属和幸存者来说意味着什么。比如林恩·辛普森（Lynn Simpson）。她在9/11事件后的第一期节目中曾讲述过自己的经历：飞机撞击大楼时，她正在世贸中心一号楼的89层工作，她又是如何走下楼梯，并在大楼倒塌前一分钟侥幸逃生的。上周我采访了她。
I wish that people wouldn't make such a big deal about the 10th anniversary. And I'm very happy when September 12 comes along.
我希望人们不要对十周年纪念大惊小怪。当9月12日到来时，我会感到非常高兴。
You're saying in a way that, for you as somebody who escaped from the World Trade Center, you'd pretty much rather not be looking back so intensely each year. If that's so, then who are these commemorations for?
你是说，作为一名从世贸中心逃出来的幸存者，你其实宁愿每年不必如此刻意地回望那段往事。如果真是这样，那这些纪念活动又是为了谁呢？
Well, I don't know.
嗯，我不知道。
Marian Fontana's husband Dave was a firefighter killed in the south tower. She was also on our show years ago, and she told me last week when we checked with her that she and her son are going to spend 9/11 not at any of the public events, but instead they're going to visit the spot at a park where Dave proposed to her years ago and where she later scattered his ashes. And then they're going to have a quiet family dinner together.
玛丽安·丰塔纳（Marian Fontana）的丈夫戴夫（Dave）是一名在南塔丧生的消防员。多年前她也上过我们的节目。上周我们联系她时，她说她和儿子不会去参加任何公开的纪念活动，而是会去公园里的那个地方——那是戴夫当年向她求婚的地方，也是她后来撒下他骨灰的地方。之后，他们会一起吃一顿安静的家庭晚餐。
See, I was wondering if when these anniversaries come up, if it's comforting or if it's more like, OK, let's relive the worst day of your life?
你看，我一直在想，当纪念日到来时，这到底是种慰藉，还是说，好吧，让我们重温你人生中最糟糕的一天？
Yeah, it's complicated. I always feel like "never forget" is such an odd-- you know, the kind of phrase of 9/11, where it's like, "never forget," but to heal, you have to forget.
是的，这很复杂。我总觉得“永志不忘”是一个很奇怪的词，你知道，这是9/11的代名词。虽然叫“永志不忘”，但要疗伤，你却必须学会遗忘。
Here we are, 9/11. And who exactly wants to watch the footage from that day again, think about it all over again? And we thought today on our program, rather than look back at that one day in 2001, it would be a lot nicer to spend most of this hour looking at where we have come since. After all, 9/11 happened to us, but the decade since, we created that ourselves. And this seems like a good time to measure just how far we've come. And to do that, we have reached out today to some of the interviewees who have appeared on our show in the last decade, whose lives seem to tell some piece of the story of what the world has gone through since September 11.
现在是9/11了。到底有谁想再次观看那天的录像，再次去回想这一切呢？我们在今天的节目中想到，与其回顾2001年的那一天，不如花点时间看看我们后来走过的路，这样会更好。毕竟，9/11事件发生在我们身上，但之后这十年是我们自己创造的。现在正是审视我们走了多远的好时机。为此，我们联系了一些过去十年中曾出现在我们节目中的受访者，他们的生活似乎讲述了世界自9月11日以来所经历故事的一部分。
We checked in with them again to see what has happened to them. And I have to say, it has been really interesting this week, putting this together and hearing what has happened and where they are in their lives now. It's been a decade, but as you'll hear, for most of them it still somehow feels like they are at the beginning of something in their lives, something they are still figuring out. We bring you their stories on this 10th anniversary of 9/11.
我们再次回访了他们，看看他们发生了什么变化。我必须说，这一周整理这些资料，倾听他们的经历以及他们现在的生活状况，真的非常有趣。十年过去了，但正如你所听到的，对他们大多数人来说，某种程度上，他们似乎仍处于人生的起点，还在不断摸索。在9/11十周年之际，我们将为你带来他们的故事。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际（Public Radio International）发行。请继续收听。
Act One, Kabul, Kabul, Kabul, Kabul, Kabul Chameleon.
第一幕，喀布尔，喀布尔，喀布尔，喀布尔，喀布尔变色龙。
Hello, hello. OK, today is September the 11th, 2002. It's actually my last night in Peshawar. I'm at a relative's house.
你好，你好。今天是2002年9月11日。实际上这是我在白沙瓦的最后一晚。我在亲戚家。
A lot of people have been affected by September 11, but our family's literally turned upside-down. Like, even me, my whole plans and my life has changed.
很多人都受到了9/11的影响，但我们的家庭生活彻底被颠覆了。即使是我，我所有的计划和我的人生也全变了。
When September 11, 2001 happened, Hyder Akbar was 16. His dad ran a hip-hop clothing store in the San Francisco area. Hyder thought that maybe he was going to become a mortgage broker like his older brother someday. But his dad and some of his uncles had fought the Soviets in Afghanistan, driving the Soviets out back in 1989. His family fled the country when the Taliban came to power, until September 11.
2001年9月11日发生时，海德·阿克巴尔（Hyder Akbar）只有16岁。他父亲在旧金山地区经营一家嘻哈服装店。海德曾想过，也许有一天他会像他哥哥一样成为一名抵押贷款经纪人。但他的父亲和一些叔叔曾参加过阿富汗抗击苏联的战争，并在1989年将苏联人赶了出去。塔利班掌权后，他的家人逃离了该国，直到9/11事件发生。
After Americans drove the Taliban from the capital, his father's old friend, Hamid Karzai, got in touch. Karzai appears in a family photo album in a picture that was taken at Disneyland maybe 30 years ago, baby-faced, standing next to Goofy. Now Karzai was leading the new interim government in Afghanistan, and he convinced Hyder's dad to sell his business and move back to help out. And Hyder, who'd never been in Afghanistan but who'd been raised on stories about all the family friends and family members who were heroes in the struggle, he wanted to go, too. And he recorded himself on those trips for our show.
在美国人将塔利班赶出首都后，他父亲的老朋友哈米德·卡尔扎伊（Hamid Karzai）与他们取得了联系。卡尔扎伊出现在一张家庭影集的照片中，那是大约30年前在迪士尼乐园拍摄的，当时他还是个娃娃脸，站在高飞旁边。现在，卡尔扎伊正领导着阿富汗的新过渡政府，他劝说海德的父亲卖掉生意，搬回去帮忙。而海德，虽然从未去过阿富汗，但从小听着那些作为抗争英雄的世交和家人的故事长大，他也想去。他把那些旅行记录了下来，供我们的节目使用。
Radio producer Susan Burton took dozens of hours of recordings and turned them into two programs, one documenting what happened on Hyder's first trip in 2002, when his father was the spokesman for the new Afghan government, and the second program the following year, when Hyder's dad was now the governor of a particularly unstable area called the Kunar Province. Over the course of these two hours, we hear Hyder grow up. When he first arrives in Kabul, he is completely green, thrilled, in this fanboyish way, just to be there.
广播制作人苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）将几十小时的录音整理成了两期节目，一期记录了海德2002年第一次旅行时发生的事情，当时他的父亲是新阿富汗政府的发言人；第二期则是次年的节目，那时海德的父亲已是库纳尔省这个极不稳定地区的省长。在这两小时的节目中，我们听着海德逐渐长大。当他第一次到达喀布尔时，他完全是个菜鸟，那种粉丝心态让他感到非常兴奋，仅仅因为能身处那里就感到满足。
Today was a really interesting day. I went to the palace today, and it was this incredible-- It was almost like going through a movie. Like, there's all the gates, and how they open and the huge locks. Almost looks like you're visiting some place in Disneyland or Universal Studios. But it was the real thing. You have infamous war lords walking this way, and famous ministers walking that way. It was pretty exciting. I mean, it's like the equivalent, I think, of a Lollapalooza or something, going backstage and getting to meet all these rock stars going back and forth. It was kind of like that. And as nerdy and dorky as that sounds, that's pretty much how it was like for me.
今天真是很有趣的一天。我今天去了王宫，那真是不可思议……简直就像走进了一部电影。所有的门，它们是如何打开的，还有那些巨大的锁。看起来简直就像是在参观迪士尼乐园或环球影城。但这是真实的。你会看到臭名昭著的军阀走这边，著名的部长走那边。这太令人兴奋了。我的意思是，这相当于去参加Lollapalooza音乐节，去后台见到所有的摇滚明星来来往往。感觉就像那样。虽然听起来可能很书呆子气，但当时对我来说确实就是那种感觉。
On these two trips, carrying a tape recorder, Hyder sees a lot. He works as an interpreter for the US military, including translating for a man, Abdul Wali, who dies while in custody after being interrogated by the Americans. He gets caught in a firefight. He walks through the devastation after a car bomb. He befriends people, especially his driver and companion, Sartor. And he vows to come back.
在这两次旅行中，海德随身带着录音机，看到了很多。他曾担任美军的翻译，包括为阿卜杜勒·瓦利（Abdul Wali）翻译。那人在接受美国人审讯后，在拘留期间死亡。他陷入过交火中。他走过汽车炸弹袭击后的废墟。他结交了许多人，尤其是他的司机兼伙伴萨托（Sartor）。他发誓会回来。
Hey, Hyder?
嘿，海德？
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Hyder, can you hear me? It's Ira.
嘿，海德，你能听到我说话吗？我是艾拉（Ira）。
Can you hear me?
你能听到我吗？
Yeah, yeah I can hear you. Can you hear me?
是的，是的，我能听到。你能听到我吗？
Yes, yes, I can hear you.
是的，是的，我能听到你。
Where are you right now?
你现在在哪儿？
I'm in Kabul.
我在喀布尔。
Are you in an office? Are you in your house?
你在办公室吗？还是在家里？
Yeah, I'm in my house, which also doubles up as my office.
是的，我在自己家里，这里同时也是我的办公室。
I reached Hyder last week by phone in Afghanistan. Some quick facts-- he's 26. After creating two amazing radio shows and writing a book with his producer, Susan Burton, he transferred from the community college that he was at to Yale University, where he graduated from. He now lives on the third floor of this house that I reached him at, and on the second floor is the NGO, the Non-Governmental Organization that he created, basically to go out and survey Afghans to understand what they're thinking and what they want, for international aid groups and others who are working in the country.
上周我通过电话在阿富汗联系到了海德。简单介绍一下——他26岁了。在制作了两个精彩的广播节目并与制作人苏珊·伯顿合著了一本书后，他从当时就读的社区学院转学到了耶鲁大学，并顺利毕业。他现在住在我通过电话联系到的这所房子的三楼，二楼就是他创办的非政府组织（NGO）。他主要是出去调查阿富汗人的想法和需求，为在该国工作的国际援助组织及其他机构提供参考。
Also living in Hyder's house these days, Sartor, his friend, and Yusef, who's one of his father's old aides and a close family friend. Hyder's uncle, Rauf Mama, comes and stays with them sometimes, too. Rauf Mama's been driven from his own home near the Pakistan border.
现在住在海德家里的还有他的朋友萨托，以及他父亲的一位老助手、亲密的世交尤塞夫（Yusef）。海德的叔叔劳夫·妈妈（Rauf Mama）有时也会来和他们住在一起。劳夫·妈妈是被迫离开了他自己靠近巴基斯坦边境的家。
So I'm just going to launch right in, OK? I have, like, a million questions here. You ready?
所以我准备直接开始了，好吗？我有一百万个问题。你准备好了吗？
Sure, sure, I'm ready. Yes, I am ready.
当然，当然，我准备好了。是的，我准备好了。
So when you were last on the radio show in 2003, the final thing you were talking about at the end of that show was about your uncle, Rauf Mama, who is a war hero from fighting the Soviets and has one eye. And then at the end of that show, you talked about this.
当你2003年最后一次上电台节目时，节目结束时你谈到了你的叔叔劳夫·妈妈，他是一位抗击苏联的战争英雄，而且只有一只眼睛。在那期节目的最后，你谈到了这一点。
It's probably about 1 o'clock at night right now. I couldn't sleep tonight. It's because that interview was so emotional. You know, when I asked him what was the hardest part ever of everything you've been through, he mentioned having to sleep next to this friend just hours after he was killed, and the hail pouring down on him and him trembling in that cold.
现在大概是凌晨1点。我今晚睡不着。因为那次采访太感人了。你知道，当我问他这一生经历过最艰难的部分是什么时，他提到在一位朋友被杀几小时后不得不睡在朋友旁边，冰雹砸在他身上，他在寒冷中颤抖。
One of the reasons I wanted to interview my uncle before I left was because I knew it was going to really have a lasting impression on me. And just in case I ever get soft and I get like, maybe I should just stay in America, or maybe, you know, that image of him having to do that will at least keep me going for another five years. And we have a really close relationship. And he really has high hopes for me. And he tells me all the time that he thinks I'm so smart and that I'm going to do so much for this country. I'm going to be pulled back here. I know it. I just can't let my uncle down.
我离开前想采访叔叔的原因之一，是因为我知道这会给我留下深刻的印象。万一我变得软弱，或者心想“也许我应该待在美国”，那么他不得不那样做的画面至少能让我再坚持五年。我们的关系非常亲密。他对我有很高的期望。他总是告诉我，他认为我很聪明，我会为这个国家做很多贡献。我会回到这里。我知道。我不能让叔叔失望。
So you were a teenager when you recorded that. What's it like to hear that now?
所以你录下那段话时还是个少年。现在听起来是什么感觉？
Disappointing. It's disappointing to hear that, because I feel like, in those years, although there was a lot of problems to deal with, it was still about, how are we going to turn things around? How is Afghanistan going to have a better future? There was still an excitement in the air about the country moving forward. And now it's more about how to make sure that it doesn't go completely to [BLEEP] again.
令人失望。听起来很失望，因为我觉得，在那些年里，尽管有很多问题要处理，但重点仍然是：我们要如何扭转局面？阿富汗如何才能拥有更好的未来？空气中仍然弥漫着国家正在向前发展的兴奋感。而现在，更多的是在想如何确保它不会再次彻底变成垃圾。
It's sobering hearing Hyder talk like this. If there was going to be one optimist left in Kabul, it would be Hyder. But he says lots of people there now are wondering which side is going to win in Afghanistan, the Americans, the Taliban. Who? Kunar Province, where his dad was governor, is in terrible shape, and the Taliban are so strong there that Hyder says that nobody wants to be seen as working with the Americans anymore.
听海德这样说令人清醒。如果喀布尔还剩下一个乐观主义者，那一定是海德。但他表示，现在那里很多人都在想，谁会赢得这场阿富汗战争？美国人？塔利班？到底是谁？他父亲曾任省长的库纳尔省情况非常糟糕，塔利班在那里势力强大，海德说，已经没人愿意被看到与美国人合作了。
You can hear in Hyder's voice how different this is, and how different he is compared to when he first got there. I asked him on the phone about what life in Kabul is like these days. Back in 2002, he remarked on how he spent a month and a half barely ever speaking with a woman or a girl.
你能从海德的声音中听出与他刚到那里时相比有多大的不同。我在电话里问他，现在喀布尔的生活是什么样的。回到2002年，他曾感慨自己有一个半月几乎没有和任何女人或女孩说过话。
Here, I'll start counting and I'll look for a woman's face. And also, I'll tell you how long it takes me. Burka, burka, burka, burka, burka. Still no woman.
在这里，我会开始数数并寻找女人的面孔。我会告诉你需要多久。罩袍，罩袍，罩袍，罩袍，罩袍。还是没有女人。
And when he returned in 2003.
而当他2003年回来时。
Kabul has changed tremendously. Right now there's three girls in front of me. All they have is a loose chador, but I see jeans underneath their cloth. But last year, burkas were probably about 95%. This year, I'd say they've dropped to under a quarter, one out of four.
喀布尔发生了巨大的变化。现在我有三个女孩在我面前。她们只披着宽松的罩袍，但我看到布料下她们穿着牛仔裤。去年，穿罩袍的比例大概是95%。今年，我想下降到四分之一以下，四个人里有一个。
Hey, Hyder, what's it like now?
嘿，海德，现在情况如何？
It's gotten much more serious than that, Ira. I feel like, at that time, again, because there was some hope there, there were some things that you could kind of look at, things like the burka, as an indication of the change. But when we just got a call a couple hours ago, Sartor being told that three people in his village were kidnapped. When Sartor's son, we had to drag-- Sartor's son is 19 years old, 18 years old. And he's in Kunar. And he is exactly of Taliban fighting age, and his father is becoming very worried about him. And we have to drag him out and make sure he stays with us here in Kabul, because the Taliban are recruiting him and it's a problem in our home now.
情况比那时严重多了，艾拉。我觉得当时之所以有希望，是因为有些迹象可以观察，比如罩袍，作为变化的指标。但我们几个小时前刚接到一个电话，萨托被告知他村里有三个人被绑架了。萨托的儿子——我们不得不把他带走——萨托的儿子才19岁，18岁。他在库纳尔。他正好是塔利班招募的战斗年龄，他的父亲非常担心他。我们必须把他拖出来，确保他留在喀布尔和我们住在一起，因为塔利班正在招募他，这现在成了我们家里的一大困扰。
It's a problem. With Sartor it's a problem. With Yusef's kid-- Yusef's kid is 10 years old. And one night-- in the village sort of everybody's kind of armed-- so suddenly he heard there's some kind of loud bang at night, once real quick. And he ran to go grab the Kalashnikov, and he asked his wife, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], have you seen the Kalashnikov? They usually have this place where they hide it. And they looked and the Kalashnikov was missing.
这是一个问题。对萨托来说是个问题。尤塞夫的孩子——尤塞夫的孩子10岁。一天晚上——村子里的人都武装起来了——他突然听到晚上有巨大的撞击声，很快。他跑去抓卡拉什尼科夫步枪，他问妻子，卡拉什尼科夫在哪里？他们通常有个藏枪的地方。他们找了找，发现枪不见了。
So he started investigating it, and found out that, later on, it ended up being his 10-year-old son who had taken it. And when he asked him why he had taken it, he said, oh, because I'm going to shoot at the Americans, because they're infidels and invaders. And he's 10 years old. And so Yusef got very worried about his son. And he took the Kalashnikov from him.
于是他开始调查，后来发现，原来是他10岁的儿子拿走了。当他问为什么要拿走时，儿子说，哦，因为我要向美国人开枪，因为他们是异教徒和侵略者。他才10岁。尤塞夫非常担心儿子。他把枪没收了。
And after that, he went-- the funny thing is, it kind of gives you a sense of who really has the control there-- he went back to the Taliban themselves, and said, look, my son is 10 years old, and because of all the propaganda and all the stuff that you guys are using here, he's getting riled up and he wants to steals the Kalashnikov and take potshots at Americans. So can you go and talk to him and say, you know, that the Taliban cut off the hands of people that do uncoordinated attacks, so you can't do anything without permission? Or something like that so he didn't do anything crazy.
更有趣的是——这让你感觉到到底是谁真正掌控着那里——他回去找塔利班本人说，听着，我儿子10岁，因为你们在这里散布的所有宣传和东西，他很激动，想偷走卡拉什尼科夫向美国人打冷枪。所以你们能不能去和他谈谈，告诉他，塔利班会砍掉那些擅自发动袭击的人的手，所以未经许可什么都不能做？或者类似的警告，这样他就不会做傻事了。
So that's kind of more an example of how much the situation has changed, and I think gives you a better indicator of the momentum and direction of this country than the amount of burkas I've seen. [DOORBELL RINGING] Sorry, that's our doorbell, and it's really tacky and loud.
所以这更能体现局势改变了多少，我认为这比我看到的罩袍数量更能反映这个国家的动向和发展方向。[门铃声] 对不起，那是我们的门铃，声音非常俗气且刺耳。
Do you need to get that?
你需要去开门吗？
No, I think Sartor's going to check who it is. I told him that I'm going to be busy upstairs. So I'll be OK.
不用，我想萨托会去看看是谁。我告诉他我会在楼上忙。我会没事的。
One of the things that's interesting listening to these shows from 2002 and 2003 is how hopeful everybody is about the new Afghan president, Hamid Karzai. And you talk, back in those shows, about how you have fond memories of him visiting with your dad when you were little. We start one of those shows showing Karzai being very charming shortly after coming to power, speaking to Afghans living in the United States. Here's a clip of him at Georgetown University, reading a question from a card.
听2002年和2003年的节目，最有趣的一点是每个人对新阿富汗总统哈米德·卡尔扎伊是多么充满希望。在那些节目中，你谈到小时候他拜访你父亲时，你对他留下的美好回忆。我们其中一期节目展示了卡尔扎伊上台不久后的魅力，他在向居住在美国的阿富汗人发表演讲。这是他在乔治城大学的一段录像，他在读一张卡片上的问题。
Specifically, how would you suggest that the younger generation of Afghans living in the US and [MUMBLES JOKINGLY].
具体来说，你会建议居住在美的阿富汗年轻一代怎么做……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, specifically, there are areas in which you have studied. Those of you who have gone through university and have acquired degrees in various fields-- medicine, engineering, computers, management, banking, business administration, all that-- these are the areas-- Statistics, by the way, we need that, very much. Accounting, auditing, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. In addition to that, if somebody wants to be the president, she or he is also welcome. So all of you are welcome.
好的，具体来说，你们学过很多领域。那些读过大学并获得各种领域学位的人——医学、工程、计算机、管理、银行、商业管理等等——这些都是领域。顺便说一下，统计学，我们需要它，非常需要。会计、审计……此外，如果有人想当总统，她或他也欢迎。所以你们所有人都是受欢迎的。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
And you, of course, are one of the young people who actually took him up on that call and went back. So since then, his government, the New York Times-- and this is a news stories, not in editorials-- the New York Times refers to his government as one of the most corrupt in the world. President Obama has called Hamid Karzai unreliable and ineffective. Secretary of State Clinton says he runs a narcostate. He faces an internal insurgency. How have your feelings about Karzai changed over the last decade?
而你，当然，是响应他号召并回国的人之一。从那时起，他的政府，《纽约时报》——这是新闻报道，不是社论——称他的政府是世界上最腐败的政府之一。奥巴马总统称卡尔扎伊不可靠且无能。国务卿希拉里称他管理着一个毒品国。他面临内部叛乱。过去十年里，你对卡尔扎伊的看法发生了什么变化？
I see Karzai as a sort of very tragic Shakespearean, almost sort of like a King Henry kind of figure. I see him as an individual whose intentions and heart was in the right place.
我认为卡尔扎伊是一个非常悲剧的莎士比亚式人物，几乎像是亨利国王那样的人。我认为他的初衷和心地是好的。
You don't see him as corrupt?
你不觉得他腐败吗？
Yes, I do. I do see him as corrupt. But I see that corruption more as a weakness rather than a greed. I don't think he's hoarding millions and millions of dollars into Swiss bank accounts so that he can live comfortably. I think he's just put in a circumstance in which he doesn't know how to deal with it, and he doesn't have the backbone to deal with it.
是的，我确实觉得。但我认为他的腐败更多是软弱而非贪婪。我不认为他在瑞士银行账户里囤积了数百万美元以便过上舒适的生活。我认为他只是身处一种他不知道如何应对的境地，而且他没有魄力去处理这些。
So my father, in 2005, walked out on him and hasn't looked back since. He said that, I like you as a friend, I like you as an individual, but you're not fit to lead this country. And I didn't spend my whole life struggling for this country so that I can ruin my name and reputation by being associated with this government.
所以，我的父亲在2005年离开了他，从此再没回头。他说，我喜欢作为朋友的你，我喜欢作为个人的你，但你不适合领导这个国家。我不是为了因为与这个政府挂钩而毁掉我的名誉和声誉，才奋斗一生的。
Since then, his dad has been going back and forth between Afghanistan and California. Hyder, meanwhile, was briefly engaged to somebody who he met at Yale, whose family was from the Middle East. And she was willing to move to Afghanistan with him for a few years, but when it became clear to everybody that Hyder intended to stay, even after they had children, even if the country continued to fall apart, at some point he had to decide between her and Afghanistan. And he chose Afghanistan.
从那以后，他的父亲就在阿富汗和加利福尼亚之间往返。与此同时，海德曾与他在耶鲁认识的一个中东裔家庭的女孩短暂订婚。她愿意和他一起搬到阿富汗住几年，但当海德打算永久定居，甚至在有了孩子后也打算留在那里，即便国家继续崩溃，大家意识到这点时，他必须在她和阿富汗之间做出选择。他选择了阿富汗。
So that's kind of what happened with that. I feel like I will have to be paying a price for what I want to do here. I feel like it's something much bigger than me sometimes. And I feel like I can't just run away from it.
事情就是这样。我觉得我必须为我想在这里做的事付出代价。我觉得这有时比我本身大得多。我觉得我无法逃避。
Hyder says that he doesn't believe that he's doing much good for the country, just running his NGO. And this is another change from who he was back when he was in college and we used to joke with him about how some day he was going to be either the foreign minister of Afghanistan or he would be out fighting in the hills with his uncle. Now he's in it for real, and he's become a hard-eyed pragmatist.
海德说，他不认为自己通过经营非政府组织对这个国家做了多少贡献。这与他在大学时又是一个变化，当时我们常开玩笑说，他未来要么会成为阿富汗的外交部长，要么会和叔叔一起在山上作战。现在他真的身处其中，已经变成了一个现实主义者。
Lately, he said to his old producer, Susan Burton, that he's beginning to wonder if it's possible to be good and also stay relevant in Afghanistan. The people who are rising to the top, the people in power, are people with guns and their own armed groups, people who aren't afraid to use violence and intimidation. And with that in mind, Hyder is thinking about basically creating his own militia. He would do that by going into the security business with some partners.
最近，他告诉老制作人苏珊·伯顿，他开始怀疑在阿富汗是否可能既保持善良又拥有影响力。那些跻身权力顶峰的人，都是拥有枪支和私人武装组织的人，是不惧使用暴力和恐吓的人。考虑到这一点，海德正考虑基本上建立自己的民兵组织。他会通过与合伙人一起进入安保行业来实现这一点。
He'd want it to be something that would eventually employ hundreds of armed men with their own trucks and their own ammunition so he could actually be a serious player in what happens in the years ahead, with the help and the political connections of his father and his uncles and all their allies. If he's going to be serious, he says, he needs resources, and he needs guns, and he needs people who shoot guns. And he's conflicted about that.
他希望最终能雇佣数百名拥有卡车和弹药的武装人员，这样他才能在未来几年成为真正有话语权的人，并借助他父亲、叔叔及其所有盟友的帮助和政治关系。他说，如果他想认真对待这件事，他需要资源，他需要枪支，他需要那些敢开枪的人。他对此感到矛盾。
Is that something-- I don't like it. To be honest with you, I don't. But knowing the situation of the country, knowing that it's not very stable right now, knowing that the use of force is something that's respected here, if you want to be relevant in there, you need to have the resources to be relevant. I didn't go to Yale to become a war lord, but I don't know. Given the realities of the situation, given the realities of my goals-- Like in the States, in the States the political systems are a bit more set, like, somebody can emerge politically because you can emerge through the party with [UNINTELLIGIBLE] resources and campaign funding and all that kind of stuff that you need to be politically relevant through the political party system.
那是……我不喜欢。说实话，我不喜欢。但了解这个国家的状况，知道目前并不稳定，知道武力在这里是被尊重的，如果你想在那里有影响力，你需要有资源。我上耶鲁可不是为了成为军阀，但不知道。考虑到现实情况，考虑到我的目标——在美国，政治制度更成熟，某人可以通过党派获得资源、竞选资金等，通过党派体系获得政治影响力。
Here, those things don't exist. They're kind of done on force of personality. And you have to kind of be able to use your own force of personality to get both sides, whether it's the politics or the resources.
在这里，那些东西不存在。一切都取决于个人魅力。你必须能够运用自己的个人魅力来获得政治支持或资源。
But you're saying the fear is just basically just, like, who you'd be associating with, that you'd be involved with a lot of kind of--
但你是在说，恐惧仅仅在于你会与什么样的人为伍，你会被卷入很多……
Yeah, yeah, yeah, who you associated with, what you get comfortable with. Like, it's kind of a joke, but let's say, 20, 30 years down the line, I am surrounded by armed guards and I have become a dictator and I have become an [BLEEP] to everybody. I think people can look back at these years and be like, wow, OK, this is where his transformation was beginning. That's what I feel like sort of right now.
是的，是的，是的，与什么样的人为伍，你会对什么感到习惯。这听起来像个笑话，但假设20、30年后，我被武装警卫包围，我成为了一个独裁者，我对每个人都成了混蛋。我想人们可以回头看这些年，会说，哇，原来这就是他转变开始的地方。这就是我现在的感觉。
And so have you already made this decision?
所以你已经做出了决定吗？
No. I don't think I've made a decision yet. I think I'm still weighing the pros and cons. And have I tested the waters? Yes. Am I looking at the possibilities of how this exactly would pan out? Yes.
没有。我想我还没做出决定。我想我还在权衡利弊。我测试过水温吗？是的。我在考虑这件事究竟会如何发展吗？是的。
I was speaking to this guy that I had met here. He's an older guy. He's, like, in his '70s. He's a French guy. His name is Dr. Gerard Chaliand. He has kind of been all over the world. I can't name a conflict that he wasn't either a participant or an observer in. He trained the Mujahideen here in the '80s. He was with the Palestinians in the '60s and '70s. He was in Eritrea. He was in all these various conflicts.
我正在和这里认识的一个人谈话。他是个老人。大概70多岁。他是个法国人。他的名字叫杰拉德·沙利安（Gerard Chaliand）。他去过世界各地。我数不出有哪个冲突他不是参与者就是观察员。他在80年代在这里训练过圣战者。他在60和70年代和巴勒斯坦人在一起。他在厄立特里亚。他参与过所有这些不同的冲突。
So I asked him, you've seen all of these different kinds of movements and you've seen many young motivated individuals like myself in these kind of circumstances, and what would you tell me to do? And he said, lay low. Lay low until 2014. I think that's kind of when people are predicting the end game being played out in this country, where some kind of situation gets established, some kind of understanding between, OK, what exactly the Americans envision here, what exactly do the Taliban. And that's when somebody like you can emerge. You don't emerge in this kind of situation, because it's too murky, it's too dirty. Just stay alive, he said. Just stay alive until 2014. And he told me that that's not going to be an easy task for you.
所以我问他，你见过各种各样的运动，见过像我这样在这种环境下充满动力的年轻人，你会告诉我怎么做？他说，保持低调。等到2014年。我想人们预测这个国家的终局会在那时上演，到那时某种局势会确立，会达成某种理解——美国人在这里设想了什么，塔利班又设想了什么。那才是像你这样的人可以脱颖而出的时机。在这种局势下你无法脱颖而出，因为它太浑浊，太肮脏了。只要活下去，他说。只要活到2014年。他告诉我这对你来说可不是容易的任务。
Hyder Akbar in Kabul. The book that he wrote with Susan Burton when he was still here in the States is called Come Back to Afghanistan.
喀布尔的海德·阿克巴尔。他在美国时与苏珊·伯顿合著的那本书名为《回到阿富汗》。
Act Two, In the Garden of the Unknown Unknowns.
第二幕，在未知之中的未知花园。
Marian Fontana, who you heard from a little bit at the beginning of the show, had the experience after 9/11 of going from a normal life to suddenly finding herself at events with the mayor and her senators and the governor. She met President Bush three times. She was interviewed everywhere. This is because, after her husband Dave died in 9/11-- he was a firefighter-- she started an organization that's now called the September 11th Families' Association. And she was heavily involved in the politics that followed, and especially in trying to get better pay for New York firefighters.
玛丽安·丰塔纳（Marian Fontana），也就是节目开头提到过的那位，在9/11之后经历了从普通生活到突然发现自己出现在市长、参议员和州长的活动中。她见了三次布什总统。她接受了各地的采访。这是因为，在她的丈夫戴夫（Dave）——一名消防员——在9/11丧生后，她创办了一个现在名为“9/11家属协会”的组织。她深度参与了随后的政治活动，尤其是致力于为纽约消防员争取更好的待遇。
We had her on the radio show back in 2005 to tell a few, truthfully, incredible stories about what it was like in this new life that she found herself in. And we only have time to play a part of one of those stories here. This story takes place two years after 9/11, on the anniversary. 9/11 also happens to be her wedding anniversary. And there was a small event at the White House that year. And the vice president of her organization, her friend, Lee, who was a firefighter and who lost a firefighter son, thought it would be helpful for them to go. But Marian didn't want to go.
2005年我们请她上电台，讲述了她在那段新生活中经历的几个真实且令人难以置信的故事。我们这里只有时间播放其中一个片段。这个故事发生在9/11两年后，纪念日那天。9/11碰巧也是她的结婚纪念日。那一年白宫举行了一个小型活动。她组织的副主席、她的朋友李（Lee）——他也是一名消防员，失去了一个当消防员的儿子——认为去参加活动会有帮助。但玛丽安不想去。
I did not feel comfortable with this administration at all and what they were doing.
我根本不觉得这个政府所做的事情让我感到舒服。
This is in the run-up to Iraq by then.
那时已经是伊拉克战争筹备阶段了。
Right. Oh yeah, were already in Iraq. And so I felt very uncomfortable. I said, oh, you don't want me to go. And he always teased me about having a big mouth and saying the wrong thing at the wrong time. And he said, no, I absolutely want to go with you.
是的。噢，是的，我们已经在伊拉克了。所以我感到非常不舒服。我说，噢，你不想让我去。他总是嘲笑我说话不经大脑，总是在错误的时间说错话。他说，不，我绝对想让你和我一起去。
Lee told her that they needed to go because they had to talk with New York Governor Pataki and he was going to be at this dinner. And so she went.
李告诉她，他们必须去，因为他们要和纽约州长帕塔基（Pataki）谈话，他会参加这场晚宴。于是她去了。
He told me it was formal, so I put on this sparkling blue gown. And we arrive at the White House and go through this elaborate security system. And I walk out into the Rose Garden and everyone's wearing business attire, black suits, including the women in brown suits. And I'm in this sparkling blue dress that I wore at my sister's wedding. And I just saw all the Secret Service men kind of-- I could just imagine what they whispering into their lapels, like, whore in the blue dress has just entered the garden.
他告诉我那很正式，所以我穿了一件亮闪闪的蓝色礼服。我们到达白宫，经过极其复杂的安保系统。我走进玫瑰园，每个人都穿着商务套装，黑色西装，包括穿棕色西装的女士。而我穿着那件我在姐姐婚礼上穿的闪亮蓝裙子。我简直能想象特勤人员在对着领口窃窃私语，就像在说“穿蓝裙子的荡妇进花园了”。
And I was furious at Lee. He's in his late 50s and short. And I felt like I looked like his hooker, basically. So we went in.
我对李非常愤怒。他快60岁了，个子又矮。我觉得自己看起来简直就像他的妓女。于是我们就进去了。
Which is really not a good feeling in the Rose Garden.
那在玫瑰园里可不是什么好感觉。
No, I was so self-conscious. And so I was just playing with the dog, because I'm just-- Lee made me promise not to do anything inappropriate, not to talk to anybody about my liberal politics. And then I'm looking around this odd conglomeration of people, including Maury Povich and Condoleezza Rice and the Rumsfelds. And I felt so uncomfortable, I just wanted to go home. I really was feeling kind of emotional about the anniversary, and feeling like a hypocrite being there.
不，我太自卑了。我只是在和狗玩，因为我……李让我保证不要做任何不恰当的事，不要和任何人谈论我的自由派政治观点。然后我看着这群奇怪的人，包括莫里·波维奇（Maury Povich）、康多莉扎·赖斯（Condoleezza Rice）和拉姆斯菲尔德夫妇（Rumsfelds）。我感到很不舒服，只想回家。那天我确实对纪念日感触良多，感觉自己像个伪君子。
And so we got up to Governor Pataki, and we chatted for a while and said what we needed to say, and then I was ready to go home. But then there was a buffet dinner and a film to see, so we had our buffet dinner. And I sat all the way in the back of the garden at this farthest picnic table in the back. And I'm eating quietly, waiting for Lee to join me. And I hear someone say, is this seat taken? And I look up and it's Donald Rumsfeld and his wife, and they want to sit at the table with me. And I was like, no, nobody's sitting here, go ahead.
于是我们走到帕塔基州长面前，聊了一会儿，说了该说的话，然后我准备回家了。但后来有自助晚餐和电影要看，所以我们吃了自助晚餐。我坐在花园的最深处，最远的一张野餐桌旁。我静静地吃着，等着李过来。我听到有人问，这里有人吗？我抬头一看，是唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德（Donald Rumsfeld）和他的妻子，他们想和我同桌。我就说，没人坐，请便。
So they sat down, and Lee joined me. And of course, Lee, having served in Vietnam and having about 28 medals on his Class A firefighter uniform, immediately got into the conversation. And Donald Rumsfeld had just gotten back from Afghanistan, so they were chatting about all this stuff. And I decided I would be a good friend to Lee and just talk to his wife, Joyce, about his daughter's rock climbing. So that's what I was, being good. But half an ear was listening to their talk.
他们坐下后，李也加入了。李曾在越南服役，在消防制服上戴着大约28枚勋章，他立刻加入了谈话。唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德刚从阿富汗回来，所以他们聊了很多。我决定做个好朋友，只和他的妻子乔伊斯（Joyce）聊她女儿攀岩的事。我当时很乖。但有一只耳朵在听他们的谈话。
And I was getting more and more upset. And I could feel my face turning red. And then, finally, Rumsfeld turned and said, "Marian, what do you think about all of this?" And I said, "Oh, you really don't want to know what I think." And he's like, "No, no, I actually really do. I'm curious what you think." And I look at Lee to get permission if this is OK, and he nods. And I said, "Well, actually I think you used the death of my husband to go into a country you have no business being in." It felt kind of like a cop-out at the time, because there was so much more I wanted say.
我越来越心烦意乱。我能感觉到脸变得通红。最后，拉姆斯菲尔德转过身说：“玛丽安，你对此怎么看？”我说：“噢，你真的不想知道我是怎么想的。”他说：“不，不，我真的很好奇你的想法。”我看着李寻求许可看行不行，他点点头。我说：“嗯，实际上我认为你利用我丈夫的死，去了一个你根本不该去的国家。”当时这听起来像是在推卸责任，因为我有太多想说的话了。
Because there's some more direct thing that you can say than, you're taking the death of my husband and using it to start an inappropriate war. What is the mean version of that? Like, what were you holding back?
因为有些更直接的话可以说，而不是“你利用我丈夫的死来发动一场不恰当的战争”。那是那句话的“刻薄版”吗？你当时憋在心里的是什么？
No, I think I was actually being good. I think if Lee hadn't kicked me under the table, I probably could have said more. And everything kind of got quiet. Rumsfeld nodded, and he said, "Thank you," and turned back to Lee and they continued their conversation.
不，我认为我当时已经很克制了。我觉得如果李没在桌下踢我，我可能会说更多。所有人都安静了下来。拉姆斯菲尔德点了点头，说：“谢谢，”然后转头回向李，继续他们的谈话。
Soon, there was a screening of a 9/11 documentary, and so they went to this tiny screening room in the White House. She's one row behind the president.
不久，他们放映了一部9/11纪录片，于是他们去了白宫一个狭小的放映室。她坐在总统后排。
And then so I was kind of up against the wall, and Lee was sitting next to me, and Condoleezza Rice, and some other guy. And then the film began, and I didn't even think about what the film was about. And the screen opens and it's the towers burning, and the shaky cameras filming it. And I lost it like I've never lost it publicly in my life. I just started almost like having an epileptic seizure of grief, sobbing really loud. And I had to get out of there. And so I literally just stood up like a hysterical woman, which I'm not but suddenly became, and started clawing my way out of the row.
然后我被堵在墙边，李坐在我旁边，还有康多莉扎·赖斯，以及其他几个人。电影开始了，我甚至没想过电影的内容。屏幕亮起，那是燃烧的世贸中心，还有颤抖的拍摄镜头。我崩溃了，这是我人生中从未在公众场合表现出的崩溃。我简直像癫痫发作一般悲伤，哭声非常响亮。我必须离开。于是我真的就像个歇斯底里的女人一样站起来，虽然我平时不是这样，但当时确实成了那样，开始拼命挤出那一排。
And I stepped on Condoleeza Rice's foot. And they had pulled a curtain over the door, and I couldn't find the knob. And I'm, like, at the door, kind of shaking the curtains, and Lee's behind me trying to find the door.
我踩到了康多莉扎·赖斯的脚。他们拉上了门帘，我找不到门把手。我在门边，摇晃着窗帘，李在我身后试图找门。
And do you think it's just the combination of being in the most alien environment possible and then suddenly just missing your husband so intensely, like it's all coming together at once, like that's why?
你觉得那是因为身处最陌生的环境，又突然极其想念你的丈夫，这一切汇聚在一起，所以才会那样吗？
Yeah, exactly. Absolutely, that's exactly what happened. And it was the anniversary, and I really wanted to be home with my son. And I had that feeling in my stomach, like I made the wrong choice. I shouldn't have come down.
是的，完全正确。绝对就是那样。那是纪念日，我真的很想和儿子在一起。我肚子里有一种感觉，觉得我做错了选择。我不该来的。
I talked to Marian again last week. She's no longer heading the September 11th Families' Association. She got tired of the politics within the organization, and the bigger politics, too, actually. And she told me that she started to feel like she couldn't make this one day in 2001 the rest of her life. Her son, Aidan, who was in kindergarten on 9/11, is now 15 years old. And she and I talked about what these anniversaries are like for him.
上周我又和玛丽安谈了谈。她不再负责“9/11家属协会”了。她厌倦了组织内部的政治，其实也厌倦了更大的政治环境。她告诉我，她开始觉得不能让2001年的这一天占据她余生的全部。她的儿子艾丹（Aidan）在9/11时还在上幼儿园，现在已经15岁了。我们谈到了这些纪念日对他来说是什么感觉。
For him, it's harder now that he's older and understands it. I think he was so young and didn't really comprehend what was happening. And I kind of kept things on a very simple, easy-to-understand scale for him. And I avoided letting him see the images of 9/11. I never took him to Ground Zero. I really tried to protect him from a lot of the violence of 9/11.
对他来说，现在他长大了，理解了这一切，反而更难了。我觉得他那时太小了，并不真正明白发生了什么。我一直让他保持在一个简单、易于理解的层面。我避免让他看到9/11的影像。我从未带他去过世贸遗址。我确实尽量保护他免受9/11暴力冲击。
That said, now that he's older and he's much more political and interested in politics, he has a lot of questions. And I try to answer them as best as I can. But I know the bin Laden capture was a very hard day for him at school. All the kids were talking about it, congratulating him, and he really had a hard time wrapping his head around that.
话虽如此，现在他长大了，对政治更感兴趣，有很多疑问。我尽我所能回答。但我知道本·拉登被抓的那天对他来说在学校非常难熬。所有的孩子都在讨论，都在祝贺他，他真的很难接受这一切。
Yeah, I read you wrote about that in salon.com back when it happened in May. And you wrote that, when he went off to school the morning after-- bin Laden was killed on a Sunday, so on Monday he went to school-- and that morning, when you dropped him off, he said he felt like a big weight off of his shoulders. And then you wrote, a little after 1:00, Aidan called. You wrote he was uncharacteristically upset. He wanted to come home after school. Everyone's talking about bin Laden. In every class they're happy he's dead, but I don't feel happy.
是的，我读过你那时在salon.com上写的文章。你写道，第二天早上他去上学时——本·拉登是在周日被杀的，所以周一他去学校——那天早上，当你送他去学校时，他说他感觉肩上的大石头卸下了。然后你写道，一点多一点，艾丹打电话来了。你写道他一反常态地心烦意乱。他放学后想回家。每个人都在谈论本·拉登。每门课上大家都很开心他死了，但我却不觉得高兴。
Yeah, he kind of was coming to terms with his own feelings about it. I think he felt uncomfortable with the celebratory nature of what was happening. In New York, he had heard that people were down at Ground Zero partying all night. And he said to me, doesn't that make us like them?
是的，他开始接受自己对此的感受。我想他对发生的那种庆祝性质感到不舒服。在纽约，他听说人们在世贸遗址通宵派对。他对我说，这难道不让我们变得和他们一样了吗？
Oh, that just seemed wrong to him.
噢，那对他来说看起来完全不对劲。
Yeah, he said it felt a little archa-- I mean, he didn't use the word "archaic," but he said it seemed a little medieval. And I kind of agree.
是的，他说感觉有点中世纪……我是说，他没用“中世纪”这个词，但他说感觉有点像中世纪。我也有同感。
In 2005, you said that you felt like you were still kind of a walking symbol for what had happened to the country. Has that worn off, or has that gotten worse as time has gone on?
2005年，你说你感觉自己像是一个国家不幸遭遇的活标本。随着时间推移，那种感觉消失了吗，还是更严重了？
Well, I think for the people who know me and my friends and family, I don't think they ever saw me that way, thank goodness. But I think it is hard. I think dating, it makes dating very challenging. I had dates cry when I tell them the story, which is a little uncomfortable, to say the least. I guess it's just not very romantic.
嗯，我想对于了解我的人，我的朋友和家人，他们从来没那样看过我，谢天谢地。但我认为这确实很难。我想约会，约会非常有挑战性。当我告诉他们我的故事时，有约会对象会哭，这至少可以说让人有点不舒服。我想这不太浪漫。
It's not sexy. No.
这不性感。不。
I've had a lot of strange and different reactions from different men on dates about--
我在约会时从不同男士那里得到了很多奇怪和不同的反应，关于……
Like what?
比如什么样的？
Well, I always hear everyone's 9/11 story, almost always, which I appreciate. It's understandable. I think they want to connect.
嗯，我总是能听到每个人的9/11故事，几乎总是这样，我很感激。这是可以理解的。我想他们是想建立联系。
Sometimes it feels a little strange, where they'll say, oh, 9/11, yeah, I was in Queens and my subway couldn't get to my stop, and it was really, really hard. And I was like, yeah.
有时感觉有点奇怪，他们会说，噢，9/11，是的，我在皇后区，我的地铁没法开到站，真的，真的很难。我就说，是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I can beat that.
我能赢过那个。
I can't sound like, yeah, that's tough. And I guess everything's relative. I try to have patience and understand. But it's sometimes like, really?
我不能表现得像，“是的，那真惨”。我想一切都是相对的。我尽量保持耐心和理解。但有时确实会想，真的吗？
Did you find yourself, just at some point you just stopped telling strangers?
你有没有觉得，在某个时间点，你就不再告诉陌生人了？
I have tried that, yes. I do try to avoid it.
我试过，是的。我确实尽量避免告诉别人。
Do you hope that this 10th anniversary, after this the anniversaries will pass with less ceremony and commemoration?
你希望这个十周年纪念日之后，之后的纪念日能减少仪式感吗？
You know, I'm not sure. I have mixed feelings about it. I mean, I do like that people remember, but for me, personally, I want to forget. So it's kind of, I'm not sure. I feel like 9/11 happened to everybody, and so I think people have this strong draw to come back to Ground Zero or to come back to 9/11 and connect with that. For me, I like to connect with the kind of moment in time that was so unique after 9/11 where the world kind of came together for a second.
你知道，我不确定。我对此心情复杂。我的意思是，我确实喜欢人们记住，但对我个人而言，我想遗忘。所以我……我不太确定。我觉得9/11发生在每个人身上，所以我觉得人们有一种强烈的冲动回到世贸遗址，或者回到9/11去和那段往事建立联系。对我来说，我喜欢连接那种9/11之后非常独特的时刻，当时全世界仿佛团结在了一起。
You mean that everybody was getting along for a second?
你是说大家有那么一瞬间和睦相处？
Yeah. It kind of gave me hope for us as a culture and as a world. And I feel like we've moved in the complete opposite direction of that, that we're more divided than we've ever been before. It's just very hard to watch.
是的。那让我对我们作为一个文化群体和一个世界产生了希望。我觉得我们已经走向了完全相反的方向，我们比以往任何时候都更加分裂。这真的很难看下去。
The thing you're describing is the thing you wish people would dwell on. I feel like even that somehow has become part of the standard, blah, blah, blah of this day. You know what I mean? I feel like, if you were to tune on to the television coverage that day, I'm sure that there'll be a lot of things in the speeches about the moment after when we all came together. And I feel like there's like--
你描述的那件事是你希望人们多关注的。我觉得即使是那一点，不知何故也成了这一天的标准套话的一部分。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得，如果你那天打开电视看报道，我敢肯定演讲中会有很多关于我们团结在一起的那一刻的内容。我觉得……
It's almost a cliche.
这简直成了陈词滥调。
It's almost a cliche in a way that's hard to even get back to that feeling.
这在某种程度上甚至让人难以回到那种感觉。
Absolutely. And yet, anyone who was involved, when I mention that, they nod vigorously because they do remember that. And it was very fleeting. But I mean, it was so profound. I really don't know if I would have made it through that time without having had the kind of whole world wrap their arms around me, is what it felt like.
绝对是。然而，任何身处其中的人，当我提到这一点时，他们都会大力点头，因为他们确实记得。那非常短暂。但我的意思是，那太深刻了。我真的不知道，如果在那段日子里，没有全世界张开双臂拥抱我的那种感觉，我是否还能挺得过来。
Marian Fontana. She wrote a book about her experience after 9/11 that is a lot like the story she's telling here on the radio. It's called A Widow's Walk. She's now working on a book about her dating experiences since 9/11 called The Middle of the Bed. And it's looking for a publisher.
玛丽安·丰塔纳。她写了一本关于她9/11之后经历的书，这和她在电台上讲述的故事很像。书名叫《寡妇之行》（A Widow's Walk）。她现在正在写一本关于她9/11后约会经历的书，名叫《床中间》（The Middle of the Bed）。正在寻找出版商。
Coming up, a story that generated more email than almost anything we have ever broadcast. We return to see what's happened in the years since. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，是一个引发了我们播出过的内容中最多邮件的故事。我们回访看看过去几年发生了什么。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today, for the 10th anniversary of 9/11, we are returning to people who we've had on the show during the past decade, people whose lives were changed by 9/11, because we wanted to see what's happened to them as the decade's proceeded. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Put on a Happy Face.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在9/11十周年之际，我们回访了过去十年中出现在节目中的人们，那些生活因9/11而改变的人们，因为我们想看看随着十年的过去，他们发生了什么。我们进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，带上快乐的面具。
On 9/11, where were you when that happened?
在9/11那天，你发生时在哪里？
I was actually in war games in Gulfport, Mississippi.
我当时实际上在密西西比州格尔夫波特的军事演习中。
This is reporter Chris Neary talking to John, who was in the Navy back then.
这是记者克里斯·尼里（Chris Neary）与当时在海军服役的约翰（John）交谈。
What are war games?
什么是军事演习？
Playing war. You do live fire, stay out in the field for two or three weeks. And at that time, we hadn't even put on our gear or anything. We're getting ready to go out to the field for war games, and someone ran in and was like, a plane just hit the Twin Towers. And we're all looking, we flipping through our manuals, like, what do we do? What do we do? What are we supposed to do? Like, this was a situation that they gave us.
玩战争。进行实弹射击，在野外待两三周。那时候，我们甚至还没穿上装备。我们正准备去野外进行演习，有人跑进来说，一架飞机撞上了双子塔。我们都在看，翻阅手册，像在想，我们该做什么？我们该做什么？我们应该做什么？就像这是他们给我们的一个演习情境。
So wait. So you didn't think it was real?
等等。所以你不觉得那是真的？
No, I didn't think it was real.
不，我不觉得那是真的。
You thought that 9/11 was a war games exercise?
你以为9/11是军事演习？
Yes. And they take this stuff kind of serious, the war games. So we don't know what's going on. We really didn't know what was going on.
是的。他们对待这些演习非常认真。所以我们不知道发生了什么。我们真的不知道发生了什么。
When did you find out that it was real?
你什么时候发现那是真的？
Maybe, like, four hours later.
大概，四个小时后吧。
Did you realize that this means that I might really be a soldier?
你有没有意识到这意味着我可能真的要当兵了？
Yes. Yes. They told us to go home and get ready.
是的。是的。他们告诉我们回家准备好。
John ended up serving in Iraq as a mortarman. Chris met him once he was out of the service, four years ago in the fall of 2007, while reporting a story on PTSD. And they hit it off right away. John was especially open about what he was going through. He was direct. He was funny. He answered the sort of questions that reporters ask, which doesn't always happen.
约翰最终以迫击炮手的身份在伊拉克服役。克里斯在他退役后，也就是四年前2007年秋天，在报道一个关于PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）的故事时第一次见到他。他们一见如故。约翰对自己的遭遇特别坦诚。他很直接。他很有趣。他回答了记者通常会问的那类问题，这并不总是会发生。
After Chris filed his story, they talked on and off for months. Then one day, after Chris hadn't heard from John in a while, he learned that John had attacked his fiancee in one of those grizzly incidents that had made the news from time to time. Here's Chris.
克里斯提交故事后，他们断断续续地聊了好几个月。然后有一天，克里斯有一阵子没听到约翰的消息后，得知约翰袭击了他的未婚妻，那是时不时出现在新闻里的那种骇人听闻的事件之一。这是克里斯的讲述。
I read the details in a 20-page police report. John slammed her head into the floor, tried to choke her, and cut her badly. Then he sat down on the floor of the kitchen with a knife and started slicing at his own chest. Reading all this, I was shocked. Afterwards, he couldn't remember what he'd done. That sometimes happens with PTSD. This American Life producer Alex Blumberg and I visited John in jail shortly after the attack.
我在一份20页的警察报告中读到了细节。约翰把她的头撞在地板上，试图掐死她，并严重划伤了她。然后他坐在厨房地板上，拿着刀开始割自己的胸口。读到这一切，我震惊了。事后，他对自己做过的事完全没有记忆。这种情况有时会发生在PTSD患者身上。《美国生活》的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我，在袭击事件发生后不久去监狱探望了约翰。
I remember waking up and here, here, still bleeding. I got stitched up some. And I'm like, who cut me, and all this? They're like, well, you did.
我记得醒来时，这里，这里，还在流血。我缝了针。我在想，是谁割的我，这一切是怎么回事？他们说，嗯，是你自己。
When you learned what happened, when you woke up and people told you what happened, do you remember what your first thought was or your first emotion was, that like--?
当你得知发生了什么，当你醒来别人告诉你发生了什么时，你还记得你的第一个想法或第一种情绪是什么吗，就像……？
My first thought was that I killed my daughter.
我的第一个想法是我杀了我的女儿。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
I thought I killed my daughter. That's my first thought. I know that I was capable of it. In no way was I like, oh no, not me. Anytime I go outside, especially around people that I like, I try to limit the time. That's most the time why I'm so paranoid, to keep them safe. And then it's like, I gotta keep them safe from me.
我以为我杀了我的女儿。那是我的第一个想法。我知道我有能力那样做。我根本没想过什么“噢不，不是我”。每当我出门时，特别是在我喜欢的人周围，我尽量限制时间。大部分时间我之所以那么偏执，就是为了保护他们安全。然后就感觉，我得保护他们免受我伤害。
It was hard to imagine him ever getting back to a normal life. I've talked with John just a few times since then. And when I checked in last month, three years after we'd talked in jail, things were a lot better. He is, remarkably, on good terms with his ex-fiancee and their daughter. He has a new girlfriend, a veteran herself. And he's pursuing singing and music production, things he dreamed of doing before the military. When I got to the studio to talk with John, he was upbeat and funny.
很难想象他能回到正常生活。自那以后，我和约翰只谈过几次。上个月我回访他时，距离我们在监狱里的交谈已经过去了三年，情况好多了。非常令人欣慰的是，他和前未婚妻以及女儿的关系很融洽。他有了新女友，也是一名退伍军人。他正在从事歌唱和音乐制作，那是他在军队前就梦想做的事情。当我到达工作室和约翰谈话时，他兴致很高，很幽默。
Hey, you sound really good, man.
嘿，你唱得真好，伙计。
I practice in the mirror every morning.
我每天早上都在镜子前练习。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, I don't want people to think I'm crazy.
是的，我不想让人们觉得我疯了。
What do you practice?
你练习什么？
Being happy, chipper. If I have any hope to ever reintegrate into a civilian world, I have to not wear a scowl. I mean, I have to be friendly. I know it seems weird. How do you forget how to do it? But it's hard.
练习如何快乐、活泼。如果我还有任何希望回归平民生活，我就不能戴着愤怒的面具。我的意思是，我必须变得友好。我知道这看起来很奇怪。你怎么会忘记怎么做呢？但这很难。
Do you feel like now the way you present yourself to others has changed, but on the inside you're still the same as you were in 2008?
你觉得现在你向他人展示自己的方式改变了吗，但内心深处你还是2008年的那个样子？
The same with coping skills. I mean, that's why I'm the same. I have the same problems. I just know how to mask them. And I know how to comfort myself somewhat without having to go get wasted, without having to just be blackout drunk.
应对技能还是一样。我的意思是，这就是我还是老样子的原因。我有同样的问题。我只是学会了如何掩盖它们。我知道如何安慰自己，而不必去买醉，不必去烂醉如泥。
Small, closed spaces still scare John. He gets panic attacks. It's hard for him to be around people for very long, which makes recording and producing music difficult.
狭小的封闭空间依然让约翰感到害怕。他会有恐慌发作。很难让他长时间待在人群中，这让录音和音乐制作变得困难。
I mean, I'm pretty sure everybody knows that crazy Vietnam vet that everybody has in their family or just on the block that lives in your neighborhood, and he's out there in his war pants, cutting the grass with his flag up. You know, that's probably going to be me in 30 years, man, just different color pants. Mine would be tan. It doesn't really go away. You know what I mean?
我的意思是，我肯定每个人都知道那个疯疯癫癫的越战老兵，在你的家族里，或者就在街区、在你邻居里，他穿着他的军裤，举着旗子割草。你知道，30年后那个人可能就是我，伙计，只是颜色不一样。我的可能是棕褐色。这真的消失不了。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah. I mean, 9/11 for the US was-- and for you-- ended up being a call to war. How do you think we've done as a country?
是的。我的意思是，9/11对美国来说——对你来说——最终变成了一次战争号召。你觉得我们作为国家做得怎么样？
Are you trying to get me in trouble, man? Seriously, you ask me that question?
你是想让我惹麻烦吗，伙计？说真的，你问我那个问题？
I am going to ask you that question, yeah.
我就要问你那个问题，是的。
I don't know, man. I think I don't really like talking political stuff at all. I love the military. I love the military, yeah. Yeah, I love what the military's done for me. But I mean, I feel like I wish that-- I don't know. When people's overseas dying, and I'm sitting here at a radio station talking about how does it feel, I feel like it's not going good. I wish that these guys was home. It's 10 years, man.
我不知道，伙计。我觉得我真的不太喜欢谈论政治的东西。我爱军队。我爱军队，是的。是的，我爱军队为我所做的一切。但我的意思是，我希望……我不知道。当人们在海外牺牲，而我坐在这里，在电台讨论感受如何时，我觉得一切都不太好。我希望这些小伙子们能回家。都十年了，伙计。
Chris Neary, who lives in New York.
克里斯·尼里，居住在纽约。
Act Four, What's Arabic for Fjord? In 2007, we told the story of an Iraqi who worked as an interpreter for US forces. His name is Basim. And like many Iraqis who helped the US, his life was threatened by other Iraqis. He was sent a DVD that showed a fellow interpreter, a colleague, a guy who he knew, being beheaded, and warning him that he would be next. So Basim fled the country with his wife and baby, and ended up in Europe.
第四幕，阿拉伯语中“峡湾”怎么说？2007年，我们讲述了一位为美军担任翻译的伊拉克人的故事。他的名字叫巴希姆（Basim）。像许多帮助美国人的伊拉克人一样，他的生命受到了其他伊拉克人的威胁。他收到一张DVD，里面显示了一位同事——他认识的人——被斩首，并警告他下一个就是他。所以巴希姆带着妻子和孩子逃离了该国，最终来到了欧洲。
At the time that we did our story, we didn't even want to say which country he was in, but now he's feeling safe enough that I can tell you that it is Norway, and he's doing great. Out of the millions of Iraqis who were made into refugees or displaced by the war, he is possibly in the best possible position. As he says, he went from the most dangerous country in the world to one of the safest.
在我们讲述那个故事时，我们甚至不想说他在哪个国家，但现在他觉得足够安全了，我可以告诉你那是挪威，他过得很好。在因战争而成为难民或流离失所的数百万伊拉克人中，他可能处于最好的境地。正如他所说，他从世界上最危险的国家来到了最安全的国家之一。
I can say that, today, me and my family are going through the same hopes and fears or worries, like any other person who was born and raised in a normal country that has not been affected by atrocities like war and an embargo for 12 years. Today we are studying, working, making sure that my son would have a gooder future here in this country.
我可以这样说，今天，我和我的家人正经历着同样的希望和恐惧或担忧，就像任何出生并成长在一个正常国家的人一样，那个国家没有受到过战争和12年禁运这样的暴行影响。今天我们在学习、工作，确保我的儿子在这个国家能有更好的未来。
How old is your son now?
你儿子现在多大了？
He's six years old. He has just started in school.
他六岁了。他刚开始上学。
Is it sobering to see him speaking better Norwegian than you do?
看到他说挪威语比你说得好，是不是很令人清醒？
No, not at all. But it is a little bit annoying sometimes at home. Just yesterday, my son told me that there's another boy at third grade who was running behind him. And I just couldn't get the real sense of the meaning of the word that he was using. And I couldn't know whether the other boy was chasing him or whether he's just playing with him. And I just had to read his body language, because I see him, he was telling it as if it was a game. So then I was kind of, OK, then I don't need to talk to the teacher.
不，一点也不。但有时在家确实有点烦人。就在昨天，我儿子告诉我三年级有个男孩在他身后跑。我实在没能弄懂他在用的那个词的真正含义。我不知道那个男孩是在追他还是只是在和他玩。我只能读懂他的肢体语言，因为我看着他，他讲述时就像那是个游戏。所以我当时就想，好吧，那我不必去和老师谈了。
Is your son old enough to ask about Iraq? And if you're going to go back there?
你儿子够大到问起伊拉克了吗？如果你们要回去那里？
Yes. We are trying to give him some answers of which it's enough to satisfy his curiosity, but it is not so harmful for his childhood. He asked why? Why did we come here if we're not originally born here? And I said, we come here because, as you can see, it is easier to live here, then your mother can study further. You can go to the kindergarten and play with all of these toys. And the people are funny and good and things like that. We didn't tell him that we were actually refugees. We tell him that we have chosen this place.
是的。我们试着给他一些足够满足他好奇心的答案，但这对他的童年并没有太大害处。他问为什么？如果我们不是在这里出生的，为什么要来这里？我说，我们来这里是因为，正如你所见，住在这里更容易，这样你妈妈可以继续深造。你可以去幼儿园玩所有这些玩具。这里的人既有趣又善良。我们没告诉他我们实际上是难民。我们告诉他我们选择了这个地方。
No, that seems like a nicer story to tell a six-year-old than we were running for our lives.
不，比起“我们在逃命”，这似乎是对六岁孩子讲述的更友好的故事。
No, we cannot tell him that.
不，我们不能告诉他那个。
Now, I'm calling you on the anniversary of 9/11. Does this anniversary mean anything to you personally? Do you usually view 9/11/2001 as a day that affected your life?
现在，我在9/11周年纪念日给你打电话。这个周年纪念日对你个人有意义吗？你通常把2001年9月11日视为影响你人生的日子吗？
Yeah, of course. It has affected my life and it has affected the lives of millions of Iraqis, even though we were not involved in those attacks in any possible manner. We're still wondering why it actually affected all our lives and it didn't affect the countries who were actually involved in supporting and financing those terrorists.
是的，当然。它影响了我的人生，也影响了数百万伊拉克人的生活，即使我们根本没有参与那些袭击。我们仍然在想，为什么它真的影响了我们所有人的生活，却没有影响那些实际上支持和资助这些恐怖分子的国家。
You mean Saudi Arabia?
你是说沙特阿拉伯？
Saudi Arabia, United Arab Emirates, Bahrain.
沙特阿拉伯、阿拉伯联合酋长国、巴林。
What's it been like for you to watch crowds seize democracy in Egypt and Tunisia and Libya after knowing what happened in your country? Like, what's it been like for you?
看着埃及、突尼斯和利比亚的民众在知道你们国家发生的事情后夺取民主，对你来说是什么感觉？比如，那对你意味着什么？
I was shocked. I was thinking in the back of my head, there was a thought that, what if the United States had waited until now? Maybe Iraq would join the club of countries that decided to liberate themselves from their dictators. But I always more logically thought that, if it wasn't for the removal of Saddam Hussein, would it be possible for the Tunisian people and the Egyptian people to realize that those presidents are not gods? They can really, if they want to, they can really get rid them.
我感到震惊。我脑海里有一个想法，那就是，如果美国一直等到现在会怎样？也许伊拉克会加入那些决定从独裁者手中解放自己的国家俱乐部。但我总是更理智地想，如果不是萨达姆·侯赛因下台，突尼斯人民和埃及人民是否可能意识到那些总统并不是神？他们如果真的想，他们真的可以摆脱他们。
Let me ask you about something else. The attacks in Norway this past July which killed 92 people, and which were designed to stir hatred against immigrants and non-Christians in Europe, what was that like for you to witness that?
让我问你别的事情。今年7月在挪威发生的袭击事件，造成92人死亡，旨在煽动欧洲对移民和非基督徒的仇恨，你目睹那件事是什么感觉？
The first hours before we actually find out who actually did it, I was really, to be honest, I was a bit afraid, like we don't need another Muslim hero to commit something like that in a peaceful country like Norway. And I was telling my wife that, if it turned out that the perpetrators, the ones who did the attacks in Norway, are Muslims who exactly look like us, we would be at home for two, three days until everything clears out.
在查出真正是谁干的那件事之前的最初几个小时，说实话，我有点害怕，我们不需要另一个穆斯林英雄在像挪威这样和平的国家犯下这种事。我当时告诉妻子，如果结果证明袭击挪威的人是和我们长得一模一样的穆斯林，我们得在家待上两三天，直到一切平息。
Do you think your son will graduate high school in Norway? Do you think you're going to be spending his entire childhood there?
你觉得你儿子会在挪威高中毕业吗？你觉得你会花他整个童年待在那里吗？
Well, yes. I do believe in that, not because I don't want to go back, not because we're not missing Iraq, but because there is no improvement at all. So why would I choose this sort of life for my son, not having a clean hospital, not having electricity, having still threats from al-Qaeda and from other religious groups? I would rather decide for my son to go on with his life here.
嗯，是的。我相信这一点，不是因为我不想回去，不是因为我们不思念伊拉克，而是因为那里根本没有改善。所以我为什么要为我儿子选择那种生活？没有干净的医院，没有电力，依然受到基地组织和其他宗教组织的威胁？我宁愿决定让我儿子在这里继续他的生活。
Act Five, Bad Teacher. In December 2006, roughly halfway between September 11, 2001 and today, we ran a story that generated more email than almost any story we have ever broadcast. The story was about a family, a happy family, whose names we changed on the radio. Five kids, including a daughter who we called Chloe, who was pretty, a good student, very popular.
第五幕，坏老师。2006年12月，大约在2001年9月11日和今天之间，我们播出了一个引发了我们播出过的几乎所有故事中最多的邮件的故事。这个故事关于一个家庭，一个幸福的家庭，我们在电台上更改了他们的名字。五个孩子，包括一个我们称为克洛伊（Chloe）的女儿，她很漂亮，成绩好，很受欢迎。
I had a lot of friends. We were into horses, basically. And we went over to each other's house just to play with them and talk about them and draw them.
我有很多朋友。我们基本上都喜欢马。我们去彼此家里就是为了玩马，谈论它们，画它们。
Chloe was 12 when we talked to her, but this story takes place back when she was eight. Her family was Muslim, and they were observant, and they lived in a suburb which didn't have many Muslims in it. Her mom liked it that way. She chose that area because she wanted them to have a life with all kinds of people in it.
克洛伊和我们谈话时才12岁，但这个故事发生在她八岁的时候。她的家庭是穆斯林，他们很虔诚，住在一个穆斯林不多的郊区。她妈妈喜欢那样。她选择那个地区是因为她希望他们能在各种各样的人群中生活。
And 9/11 did not change anything for them. They weren't discriminated against. Chloe's friends didn't care that she was a Muslim. All fine, until the first anniversary of 9/11 in 2002. Here's Chloe's mom, who we'll call Sari.
而9/11并没有改变什么。他们没有受到歧视。克洛伊的朋友并不在意她是穆斯林。一切都很好，直到2002年9/11一周年。这是克洛伊的妈妈，我们叫她萨里（Sari）。
I picked up the children from school that day, and she was in tears. She was inconsolable. She wasn't even making sense. She just was crying and crying.
那天我从学校接孩子们时，她在哭。她伤心欲绝。她甚至语无伦次。她只是在哭，一直在哭。
Apparently, as part of the lesson for the 9/11 anniversary, the teacher in Chloe's class had passed out a slim paperback intended to educate students about the 9/11 tragedy.
显然，作为9/11纪念日课程的一部分，克洛伊班上的老师分发了一本纤薄的平装书，旨在教育学生关于9/11的悲剧。
On the cover, it was a picture of the World Trade Center in flames.
封面上是一张世贸中心在火焰中的照片。
And the first thing was like, September 11 was a horrible day. Thousands and thousands died. And it said, who did it? We don't know, but here's a clue.
第一件事就是说，9月11日是可怕的一天。成千上万的人死亡。上面写着，是谁干的？我们不知道，但这里有个线索。
Muslims hate Christians. Muslims hate Americans. Muslims believe that anyone who doesn't practice Islam is evil, and that the Koran teaches war and hate.
穆斯林憎恨基督徒。穆斯林憎恨美国人。穆斯林认为任何不信仰伊斯兰教的人都是邪恶的，《古兰经》教导战争和仇恨。
There were some pictures of Muslim ladies wearing the headscarf, hijab. And some of them said, hey, those weird ladies, her mom's one of them. And then they just all looked at me and said, you're one of those bad Muslims, aren't you? And I just said, no, no, I'm not.
书里有一些穆斯林妇女戴着头巾的照片。其中一些照片说，嘿，那些奇怪的女人，她妈妈就是其中之一。然后他们都看着我说，你也是那些坏穆斯林之一，对吧？我就说，不，不，我不是。
That's when the taunting began. It was just overnight.
那就是嘲弄开始的时候。这简直是一夜之间发生的。
They called me loser Muslim and Osama. Like, they all saw me as a different person. Before reading the book, I was just a normal child. And then I turned into an Islamic extremist who hated the world and wanted to kill everybody. And there's a big difference there.
他们叫我“失败的穆斯林”和“奥萨马”。就像，他们都把我视为另一个人。在读那本书之前，我只是一个普通孩子。然后我就变成了一个憎恨世界并想杀死所有人的伊斯兰极端分子。这两者之间有很大区别。
Alix Spiegel, who reported this story for our show, picks up now with what happened next.
为我们节目报道这个故事的阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）现在接着讲述后来发生的事情。
The teasing just got worse from there. Even her siblings were targeted. Boys on the playground would surround her sister and pretend to pee. There was nothing Chloe could do to stop it. No matter what she said, it didn't matter, in part because the teacher of her class also seemed hostile to Muslims. And eventually, all of her friends stopped talking to her. This made her physically ill. She wouldn't get out of bed for days at a time. Some of her hair turned gray. She was eight.
嘲弄从此愈演愈烈。甚至她的兄弟姐妹也成了目标。操场上的男孩们会围住她姐姐并假装撒尿。克洛伊无法阻止。无论她说什么都没用，部分原因在于班上的老师似乎也对穆斯林充满敌意。最终，她所有的朋友都不再和她说话了。这让她身体上感到不适。她连续几天不出卧室。她的一些头发变灰了。她才八岁。
Now, in 2004, the US Department of Justice actually did an investigation of what happened to Chloe and found that Chloe's teacher in the school had behaved inappropriately, contributing to an atmosphere where Chloe was brutally harassed by her peers. The Justice Department required the school to take a variety of actions. But in some ways, by that point, it was already too late. Chloe had been so traumatized, she dropped out. And worse, her family had been torn apart.
现在，2004年，美国司法部确实对克洛伊发生的遭遇进行了调查，发现克洛伊学校的老师表现得不恰当，促成了一个克洛伊被同龄人残酷骚扰的环境。司法部要求学校采取一系列行动。但在某种程度上，在那一点上，已经太迟了。克洛伊受到了如此严重的创伤，以至于退学了。更糟糕的是，她的家庭四分五裂。
They'd picked up and moved away to put Chloe into a new school. But it wasn't far enough for Chloe's father. Chloe's father had grown up in the West Bank. And after what happened to his daughter, he decided that his family, in particular, and Muslims in general were no longer safe in America. America, he concluded, hated them. He wanted the family to move with him back to the West Bank, but Sari couldn't agree.
他们搬走了，送克洛伊去了一所新学校。但这对克洛伊的父亲来说还不够远。克洛伊的父亲在西岸长大。在女儿遭遇这些事后，他认定他的家庭，特别是他们，以及穆斯林整体在美国不再安全了。他断定，美国恨他们。他想让全家跟他搬回西岸，但萨里无法同意。
Well, I was born and raised in this country, and I'm aware of what makes this country great. And I know that what happened to our family, it doesn't speak to American values. And I feel like this is such a fluke. And I have to believe this is not what America's about. I know that. But I don't think that's the same for my husband.
嗯，我是在这个国家出生并长大的，我知道什么让这个国家变得伟大。我知道发生在我们家庭的事并不代表美国价值观。我觉得这只是个巧合。我必须相信这不是美国的本来面目。我知道这一点。但我不认为我丈夫也是这么想的。
So Sari and her husband divorced. Her husband moved to the West Bank alone, and she and the kids stayed in America. But when I called her recently, she told me that the last five years have not been good to her family, particularly, she says, to Chloe, who's now 17.
所以萨里和丈夫离婚了。她丈夫独自搬到了西岸，她和孩子们留在了美国。但当我最近联系她时，她告诉我过去五年对她的家庭来说并不好，特别是，她说，对现在17岁的克洛伊来说。
Well, since then, she has been in three different schools. Each of those schools were a challenge.
嗯，从那以后，她去了三所不同的学校。每一所学校都是挑战。
What kind of things would happen?
会发生什么样的事？
Well, for example, at the high school this past school year, at one point my daughter walked into the school library and about nine ROTC kids were seated at a table along with their instructor, and they began taunting her and calling her a raghead, saying she came from a religion of messed-up killers. So it's just been very hard.
嗯，例如，在高中过去这一学年，有一次我女儿走进学校图书馆，大约九个ROTC（预备役军官训练营）的孩子和他们的指导员坐在桌旁，他们开始嘲弄她，叫她“破布头”（Raghead），说她来自一个充斥着杀手的宗教。所以真的非常艰难。
Hard in a bunch of ways. This past spring, Sari got the news that her ex-husband had died. And the civil lawsuit that the family had filed against Chloe's old school dragged on for years, a constant reminder of what had happened. Two weeks ago, the school settled for a tiny amount. Still, Sari says, despite all this, Chloe is mostly managing.
在很多方面都很艰难。去年春天，萨里收到消息说她的前夫去世了。家庭对克洛伊老学校提起的民事诉讼拖延了多年，不断提醒着曾经发生的事。两周前，学校以极少的金额和解了。尽管如此，萨里说，尽管经历这一切，克洛伊大多还是能应付得来。
She's a remarkable young lady. She'll be entering her senior year of high school. And academically, she's doing great. It does concern me that she is not very social. The entire summer passed and she never got together with any friends.
她是个了不起的年轻女士。她即将进入高中的最后一年。在学业上，她做得很好。我不太社交这一点确实让我担心。整个夏天过去了，她从未和任何朋友聚在一起。
What does she do with her days?
她平时怎么打发日子？
She hangs out with her siblings. They like to bake a lot.
她和兄弟姐妹待在一起。他们喜欢烘焙很多东西。
Probably the biggest change for Sari since I talked to her five years ago was that, back then, she was adamant that what had happened to her family was a fluke. And hundreds of our listeners actually wrote in to agree with her on this. She says, at the time, she found these letters very reassuring. But slowly over the last five years, she's really changed her mind. This was no fluke.
萨里五年前和我交谈以来最大的变化是，当时她坚持认为发生在他们家庭的事是个巧合。我们数百名听众实际上写信支持她这一观点。她说，当时她觉得这些信非常让人安心。但在过去五年里，她确实改变了主意。这绝不是巧合。
I think if I felt that way it would be delusional, because the past seven years really speak for themselves. It's just been a barrage of intolerance and ugliness. And really, I feel like our world back then was turned upside-down, and life as we knew it before is no longer what it was. Even the mosque that we used to attend, which is about 45 minutes away, someone randomly started shooting into the mosque. And I haven't been back since then, because I just won't put my kids at risk. But that tells you that, even amongst our so-called own kind, amongst Muslims, we're really not safe. We're a community under siege.
我想如果我还那样觉得，那就是自欺欺人，因为过去七年本身就说明了一切。这简直是一场不容忍和丑陋的围攻。真的，我觉得我们的世界那时被彻底颠覆了，我们曾经了解的生活再也不是以前那样了。甚至我们曾经参加的清真寺，距离约45分钟路程，有人随机开始向清真寺射击。从那以后我就没回去过，因为我不想让孩子冒险。但这告诉你，即使在我们所谓的自己人中间，在穆斯林中间，我们也真的不安全。我们是一个被围攻的社区。
So this is where I try to figure out if Sari's right, if Muslims in this country really are a community under siege. And that is a tricky question to answer. I can tell you that the number of hate crimes against Muslims are still much higher than they were before 9/11. In the last year for which the FBI provides statistics, 2009, hate crimes against Muslims constituted around 10% of all hate crimes nationwide, even though Muslims are only about 1% of the population. And according to a poll published last week by the Pew Research Center, the majority of Muslims are like Sari. They feel like 9/11 made their lives more difficult.
所以，我试着弄明白萨里是否正确，如果这个国家的穆斯林真的被围攻了。这是一个棘手的问题。我可以告诉你，针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪数量仍然比9/11之前高得多。根据联邦调查局提供统计数据的最后一年，即2009年，针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪占全国所有仇恨犯罪的10%左右，尽管穆斯林仅占人口的1%左右。根据皮尤研究中心上周发表的一项民调，大多数穆斯林像萨里一样。他们觉得9/11让他们的生活变得更艰难了。
But at the same time, around 80% say they're satisfied with their lives in the US. In other words, it's a complicated picture. It's complicated for Sari, too. She's American. Her kids are American. And she doesn't want her children to give up on this country. And so, she says, she's given them some very targeted reading materials.
但与此同时，约80%的人表示他们对在美国的生活感到满意。换句话说，这是一个复杂的情况。对萨里来说，情况也同样复杂。她是美国人。她的孩子是美国人。她不想让她的孩子放弃这个国家。所以，她说，她给他们提供了一些非常有针对性的阅读材料。
The kids have read about Japanese-Americans and what they've gone through post-World War II. And eventually, that passed. I'm hoping that this will pass, too.
孩子们读过日裔美国人的历史以及他们在二战后所经历的一切。最终，那过去了。我希望这一切也会过去。
When it will pass, though, is not entirely clear to Sari.
然而，这一切何时过去，对萨里来说并不明确。
So far it's been 10 years since 9/11, so I don't know. I wish it would happen before the kids' childhoods are over. That would be really nice.
到目前为止，距离9/11已经过去10年了，所以我不知道。我希望能在孩子们童年结束之前发生。那真的会很棒。
This fall, the family's moving again, hoping that will help. Sari's looking for a job.
今年秋天，全家要再次搬家，希望会有帮助。萨里正在找工作。
Alix Spiegel is a correspondent for NPR News.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔是NPR新闻的记者。
Act Six, Clutter. Let's end today's show with somebody who was at the World Trade Center on that day in 2001. When I first talked to Lynn Simpson less than two weeks after the towers collapsed, she was still having trouble sleeping. She'd escaped from the 89th floor, and she kept waking up, thinking about it.
第六幕，杂乱。今天节目的最后，我们采访了一位2001年那天身处世贸中心的人。当我第一次在双塔倒塌后不到两周和林恩·辛普森谈话时，她仍然难以入睡。她从89层逃了出来，她一直醒着，想着那件事。
For the first several nights, I would wake up in the middle of the night and just have those images of the towers in my mind, and the smoke. And also, that was when I couldn't get the smell out of my hair, the very acrid dust smell. And it's a smell that's on my clothes. I have the clothes that I was wearing that day, my shoes, my socks, my slacks, my top, even the little-- I wear a little thing in my hair which keeps my hair clipped back. And I don't know what to do with them.
最初的几个晚上，我会在午夜醒来，脑海里全是双塔的影像，还有烟雾。此外，那时我的头发里总有挥之不去的味道，那种非常刺鼻的灰尘味。那是粘在我衣服上的味道。我还留着那天穿的衣服，我的鞋子，袜子，长裤，上衣，甚至那个小小的……我头上戴着个小东西把头发别在后面。我不知道该怎么办。
You still have them?
你还留着它们？
I still have them. I don't know what to do with them. I don't want to throw them away. I don't want to have them cleaned.
我还留着。我不知道该怎么办。我不想把它们扔掉。我不想送去干洗。
Why don't you want to throw them away or have them cleaned?
为什么不想扔掉或送去干洗？
I don't know. I don't know. I just, I can't quite let go of them. It is a bunch of trash, but it happened to me and I survived. I just know that I have them in a bag, and I keep the bag in a little corner. And I will eventually do something with them, because that's clutter, and clutter is not good. But right now I just can't do that.
我不知道。我不知道。我只是，我无法放下它们。这虽然是一堆垃圾，但这发生在我身上，我活了下来。我知道我把它们放在一个袋子里，把袋子放在一个角落里。我最终会处理它们，因为那是杂乱，而杂乱是不好的。但现在我就是做不到。
So when you and I spoke 10 years ago, you still had the clothes that you had worn that day to work. And you said that it was hard to throw them out. So when did you finally throw out the clothes that you wore on September 11?
所以当我和你10年前谈话时，你还留着那天上班穿的衣服。你说很难扔掉它们。所以你最后是什么时候扔掉你9月11日穿的衣服的？
I didn't.
我没有。
Oh, you didn't?
噢，你没有？
No, I didn't. I haven't done anything with them. I'm--
没有，我没有。我还没处理它们。我……
Are they still in the bag on the floor?
它们还在地上的袋子里吗？
--reluctant to say. They're in the little bag. However, they have moved from the floor in the corner into the top of a closet. So now the clutter's out of my sight.
不愿提及。它们还在那个小袋子里。不过，它们已经从角落的地板上移到了衣柜顶上。所以现在杂乱的东西不在我视线内了。
That's good. OK, that's a good system.
那很好。好吧，那是个好系统。
But I'm a little scared to look in them now.
但我现在有点害怕看它们了。
And do you ever pull them out and look at them?
你有没有试过拿出来看看它们？
No, no.
没有，没有。
Lynn doesn't work now. She doesn't live in New York anymore. She's in Pennsylvania. She finds she can't even visit New York City. She's one of an estimated 10,000 first responders and civilians who suffer PTSD related to the 9/11 attack. The symptoms? They're jittery, they overreact to loud noises, they have trouble concentrating. Lynn says that she has no idea why she is one of the people who reacted this way, and not one of the many people who went on with their lives.
林恩现在不工作了。她不再住纽约了。她在宾夕法尼亚州。她发现自己甚至无法造访纽约市。她是估计一万名与9/11袭击相关PTSD症状的急救人员和平民之一。症状？他们易怒，对巨响反应过度，难以集中注意力。林恩说她根本不知道为什么自己是那些反应如此激烈的人之一，而不是那些继续生活的许多人中的一个。
She still has an incredibly hard time sleeping. She's not replaying moments from 9/11 at night, she says. Now it's just a kind of free-floating anxiety. And just last month, a few weeks before the 10th anniversary, she finally sold her old apartment in Manhattan. She'd had renters there, figuring that eventually she'd move back.
她晚上依然极难入睡。她说，她晚上不再反复重温9/11的时刻，现在只是一种漂浮的焦虑。就在上个月，10周年纪念日几周前，她终于卖掉了在曼哈顿的旧公寓。她一直把它租出去，以为最终会搬回去。
I didn't want to do it. I fought selling that apartment.
我不想卖。我抗拒卖掉那个公寓。
Was part of selling the apartment you had to admit to yourself, OK, I'm never going to get over this?
卖掉公寓是不是因为你不得不向自己承认，好吧，我永远也无法摆脱这件事了？
Yes. Definitely. And it's very hard to admit that you're not going to be back to your old self, whether it's something whether you had an accident or hip surgery or whatever it is, you've changed. September 11th changed me. And no matter how much I try and talk myself into the fact that I'm going to get back to it, I will go back, I will be the person that I was, it's not going to happen. And I've accepted that. And once I accepted it, it was OK.
是的。绝对是。承认自己回不到以前的样子真的很难，无论是发生了事故还是做了髋关节手术，你都变了。9月11日改变了我。无论我多么努力说服自己会好起来，我会回去，我会成为以前那个人，但这不会发生。我已经接受了。一旦接受了，也就没事了。
We spent this hour talking about what has changed in the last decade, and what has happened because of 9/11. 9/11's become a symbol. It's become a rallying cry. But it was also a day, a terrifying day. So let's close our broadcast with Lynn's account from back then of what that day was like for her, in the towers when the planes hit, escaping just a minute before the building collapsed.
这一小时我们一直在谈论过去十年发生了什么，以及因为9/11发生了什么。9/11变成了一个符号。它变成了一个集结口号。但它也是一天，恐怖的一天。所以让我们以林恩当时讲述的那天在双塔里、在建筑物倒塌前一分钟逃生的经历来结束我们今天的广播。
Well, there were five of us in the office. We were the early birds. And all of a sudden, there was an enormous crash, and the building actually shook. We could feel it shake. The lights went out. The sprinklers came on. The ceiling came down. The file cabinets fell. Everything started toppling. And smoke immediately filled the entire office.
嗯，办公室里有五个人。我们是早到的人。突然，一声巨大的撞击，建筑真的摇晃了。我们能感觉到摇晃。灯灭了。喷水灭火器打开了。天花板塌了。文件柜倒了。一切开始倒塌。烟雾立即填满了整个办公室。
On the floor where you were, how many floors were you from where the airplane hit?
在你所在的楼层，你距离飞机撞击的地方有几层？
I believe the airplane hit either just above or just about the 89th, 90th, 91st floor. The only reason that I'm here, partly, is because the airplane hit on the other side of the building. The lights were out. It was smoky. It was dim. And it was getting very hot. I did try the emergency stairwell, and that door was locked. And we drank water. We covered our noses. And I called my boss, my boyfriend, and my mother.
我相信飞机撞击了89、90、91层上方或附近。我之所以还在这里的部分原因，是因为飞机撞击了建筑物的另一侧。灯灭了。到处是烟。光线很暗。而且变得非常热。我试过应急楼梯，那扇门锁着。我们喝了水。我们捂住鼻子。我给我老板、男友和我妈妈打了电话。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
I said to all of them, I'm all right. I don't know what's happened, but I'm all right. And I told John, I said the doors are locked. I can't get out. I can't get down the stairway. A few minutes after that, people knocked on the door and there were people, men with flashlights knocking on the door saying, come out, and let's go downstairs.
我对他们所有人都说，我很好。我不知道发生了什么，但我很好。我告诉约翰，我说门锁着。我出不去。我无法下楼梯。几分钟后，有人敲门，有人，带着手电筒的男人敲门说，出来吧，让我们下楼。
The stairwell that you hadn't been able to get into before?
是你之前没能进去的楼梯间？
The stairwell that I had tried before. But then we started down. And about the 83rd floor, we had to cross over. And we crossed over. That floor was devastated. It was pitch black, full of smoke. The sprinklers were coming down. The ceiling had come down. We had to hold hands to walk across it. And the only light we basically had was one man's cell phone. And we made our way across that to another stairwell. And then we proceeded down, I believe to 78.
就是我之前试过的楼梯间。但然后我们开始下楼。大约在83层，我们不得不穿过去。我们穿过去了。那一层被毁坏了。漆黑一片，到处是烟。喷头喷着水。天花板塌了。我们必须手牵手走过去。我们唯一的照明基本上是一个人的手机。我们穿过那里到达另一个楼梯间。然后我们继续下楼，我相信到了78层。
So at 78, we had to cross to another set of stairs. And when we crossed on 78, it was as if nothing had happened. The lights were on, no smoke, air conditioning, carpeting. It was all perfect.
所以在78层，我们不得不穿到另一组楼梯。当我们穿过78层时，好像什么都没发生过一样。灯亮着，没有烟，空调，地毯。一切都很完美。
How strange. That must've been so strange for you all.
太奇怪了。那对你们所有人来说一定太奇怪了。
It was very peculiar, very peculiar to go from one extreme to the other. But at 78, we had to make a decision. There were two exit signs. And one, I've since learned, that one exit went down to one floor and then stopped. It was just dead. And the other exit, which somebody said, trust me, I know we have to go down this staircase. And we did. We trusted that person, and we went down that staircase. And that led us to the bottom.
那太奇特了，从一个极端到另一个极端太奇特了。但在78层，我们必须做个决定。有两个出口标志。一个是，我后来才知道，那个出口通向下一层然后就停了。那是死胡同。另一个出口，有人说，相信我，我知道我们必须走这个楼梯。我们做到了。我们相信那个人，走下了那个楼梯。那把我们带到了底层。
And then we continued down. We had to move over to the side, because the firemen in full gear were coming up. And they started-- they met us at about 50-- and they started coming up. And then we simply continued down to the plaza level. They told us, do not look up, do not look out, do not look down, just keep going, and we need you to hurry, run, could you jog?
然后我们继续下楼。我们必须让开到一边，因为全副武装的消防员正在往上冲。他们开始……在50层左右遇到我们……他们开始向上。然后我们简单地继续走到广场层。他们告诉我们，不要向上看，不要向外看，不要向下看，一直走，我们需要你们快点，跑，能慢跑吗？
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Mickey Meek. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager.
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我制作，本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）和阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）参与。资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。米奇·米克（Mickey Meek）协助制作。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是制作经理。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是办公室经理。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's up late saying this after every story I do:
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ的管理层监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）负责，他在我做完每个故事后，总是深夜说这话：
I couldn't sleep tonight. It's because that interview was so emotional.
我今晚睡不着。因为那次采访太感人了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
[MUSIC - "NEW YORK, NEW YORK" BY RYAN ADAMS]
[音乐 - 瑞安·亚当斯（Ryan Adams）的《New York, New York》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。